pues hasta ahora es un panorama de
bastante incertidumbre de expectativa
puesto que como bien lo decía Raúl un
nuevo sobres acaba de anunciar hace unos
minutos que un nuevo sobre también ha
sido interceptado en la Embajada de
Estados Unidos en Madrid con ese último
sobre serían Ya seis los
paquetes de similares características
que han llegado en las últimas horas a
distintos lugares del país el primero
del que se tuvo constancia fue el que
explotó ayer el único que ha explotado
de hecho y el que ha causado heridas
leves a un trabajador de la embajada de
Ucrania en Madrid el segundo horas
después salió a la luz de que había sido
también interceptado otro paquete de
similares características en una empresa
de armas en Zaragoza es una ciudad que
está a mitad de camino entre Madrid y
Barcelona unas armas que fabrican esa
empresa que habían sido enviadas al
frente a Ucrania para luchar contra las
rusas un tercero fue recibido en la base
aérea militar de torrejón de ardoz aquí
en Madrid también ayer o bueno en las
horas de la madrugada entre ayer y hoy y
estaba dirigido al centro de satélites
que es la agencia de inteligencia
geoespacial de la Unión Europea es decir
todos estos objetivos bastante
relacionados con la geopolítica con la
guerra en Ucrania además el Ministerio
de defensa esta mañana confirmó que otro
paquete iba dirigido a la ministra de
defensa Margarita Robles pero también
fue interceptado y finalmente hoy la
moncloa hizo público Aunque este paquete
había llegado el 24 de noviembre lo hizo
hoy público la llegada de este paquete
de este sobre también con artefactos
explosivos o pirotécnicos
dirigidos al presidente del gobierno
español Pedro Sánchez por ahora lo que
han hecho las autoridades es pedir calma
pedir prudencia y reforzar seguridad en
edificios públicos y en las embajadas en
todo el territorio nacional Marina ahora
le pregunto qué se sabe del origen de
estos sobres de donde pudieron o
provenir de dónde pudieron ser enviados
Pues según las primeras investigaciones
de la policía y como venimos diciendo es
que esto está pasando Desde horas de la
tarde ayer a la una de la tarde hora de
Madrid las primeras investigaciones de
la policía aseguran bueno creen que el
origen Es nacional Aunque la delegada de
gobierno en Aragón que es donde está
Zaragoza esta ciudad donde llegó donde
estaba la empresa de armas decía que el
origen era Ucrania pero no nada se puede
confirmar hasta el momento son las
primeras horas de la investigación a
manos de la audiencia nacional y de la
policía sin embargo el embajador de
Ucrania aquí en Madrid dijo en
entrevista con la televisión pública
española que
estaba apuntando sin nombrar nombres
pero apuntaba a un posible origen ruso
de estos artefactos él decía textual
sabemos los métodos terroristas del país
agresor sin embargo la embajada de Rusia
en Madrid ha negado los hechos ya
condenado estos ataques diciendo que
todo ataque terrorista o cualquier
amenaza sobre todo a delegaciones
diplomáticas es condenable el gobierno
como bien decimos llama a la prudencia y
dice que aunque hasta el momento estos
hechos pues son preocupantes pero no lo
suficientemente preocupantes como para
Elevar el nivel de alerta terrorista en
el país que en el momento se encuentra
en el nivel 4 de 5 Es decir alto